and now Tim Dylan is going to have
[Music]
welcome to Tim Dylan's going to hell
everybody it's a nighttime podcast right
here in Los Angeles California Devon
cost is back it's great to be back how
long were you gone oh like a week and a
half I think road trip road trip moving
my girlfriend out to LA from Dallas
driving back with her car that broke
down what kind of car
it's a Mazda cx-7 2008 her aunt like
David herbes or daughter's car yeah
so they got we got some work done on it
like like just for like take it in like
is it okay for a road trip or theme
charges like $40.00 through a radiator
flush also [ __ ] that's a lot you know
$400 yeah that's a lot it's fine they
say it's fine
within half a mile of driving it back to
her place the engine starts smoking we
have to pull it over we get a tow truck
driver to come out from Allstate they
only you know have tow truck drivers
from like Saudi Arabia that drankin
grunts like yeah buddy knows what's
going on yeah we have him take it back
to the same mechanic but even though I'm
like I don't know I feel like they
[ __ ] us since they just worked on yeah
and it broke we get back to the next
morning tires flat the tow truck driver
just popped one of the tires just
because I didn't care about you know
tying it up right onto the [ __ ] tow
truck it was just an endless thing then
they charged us eight hundred dollars
for an air conditioning compressor and
and then we're like having when you when
you when you when you're on the side of
the road and you're [ __ ] you treated
worse than a pedophile who's like caught
in a schoolyard it really it when you
were treated like you are when you're on
the side of the road you're at your most
vulnerable and helpless yep when you
were in this Long Island Mafia owned tow
truck company's owned the parkways right
so Oh Triple A will tell you they're
like we don't we'll reimburse you but we
don't even go on the North East we don't
even do that so you call Johnny and
Vinny's our removal yeah Johnny's towing
and
hook you up and some guy pulls up he's a
guy how you dawn my friend let me his
car once a lot of people lend me their
cars their homes things like that right
and I expected the things you lend me to
be in good condition mm-hmm that's the
reality
yeah who are lending me Yeah right car
this [ __ ]
lend it to me and the thing breaks down
and I call him up and I screaming them I
go in now when this happens to you do
you look at the girlfriend do you start
going wild I just
I mean well no cuz she would freak out
right so if I like started like
complaining too much being myself alone
oh my god it's [ __ ] yeah it's over
I'm just screaming at the tow truck
driver I'm screaming at the mechanic so
yeah I'm gonna pretend that they [ __ ]
with it and I know you're up to
something and Chile with her around I
have to be like diplomatic a little bit
I have to pretend I know anything about
cars
yeah radiators I don't know I try to get
in with the tow truck people and I go
let's I'll get in on a scam I'll break
more of the car just cut me in tell me
what I need to do once it gets to that
level you're it's like you're in debt to
the car la cosa nostra like you're it's
like the Mafia they have you by the
balls you need to get around ya and they
control you having transportation I
don't want to buy a car here I've been
in LA about a week and I'm burring and
uber costs money if you're going all
over the place and I spent $80 the other
night on uber to perform at a coffee
house ok 80 I spent $30 to go to Santa
Monica welcome to LA men I make 10
I got venmo $10 which is worse than
nothing it is worse you'd rather get
nothing you get ven mode me ten then my
friend guilted me she goes you said you
would do our show too so I said okay and
then I got in a 30 minute 45 dollar uber
all the way to the east side wherever
the [ __ ] they took up coffee house I'm
gonna go bankrupt doing comedy here like
I'm gonna I'm spending more money right
getting to the place that you're getting
from the comedy and it's bad yeah you're
also your self-esteem is just I got and
here's the problem you gotta watch out
for who books you here this is certain
and I don't want to offend anyone here
but here's the reality of what is going
on do you know have you seen like a
horror movie or like the walking dead or
bird box or any of these zombie movies
these post-apocalyptic movies where like
everybody gets a disease right and
there's always a scene in the movie
where a guy should you know like eight
people that haven't been turned into
zombies holed up somewhere and then
somebody comes into the thing and
they're trying to figure out like is
this person fearow
right have they been bit you can't say
so this is the thing when you get booked
on a show you stucco so I look at this
one comic she books me she was ham a fan
I got two shows for ya so I said okay
really cool then I look at her Facebook
and I see her Facebook profile has every
club she's ever worked at like Ryan
comedian at Comedy Store comedian at
improv comedian at flatbreads comedian
at desk right Medianet haha comedian at
so immediately as soon as I see that I
go she's been bit
she's fear she's fear she's fear which
means she's mentally ill she's no longer
with us
yeah he's no longer healthy she's no
longer fighting the good fight she's
been bit she's she has the disease has
the disease she's got the itch yeah real
bad so I'm a little skeptical of the
show but I figure it's probably just a
regular shitty show right that this song
people yeah that this zombie has booked
me on because that's what comedians who
don't succeed become zombies because
they're running on an operating system
and it isn't human right and not human
anymore right you're not having human
feelings in in around I don't know
you're out there in the [ __ ] so I
show up to this lounge in the Studio
City at seven [ __ ] p.m. it's today
it's the day and it's a lounge okay I go
in and there's a there's a bouncer there
and he goes hey man he puts his hand up
like woah like where yeah where do you
think you're going like who the [ __ ] are
you immediately I know it's a problem he
goes are you audience or you on the show
and I'm like I'm on the show and you
guys all right what's your name goes
write it down so I write it down and
then I swear to God he goes ledge
Blee so I write it down again are you
yeah more legibly and he goes did you
get a chance to share the flyer the guy
at the door asked this to me the flyer
where my name is spelled wrong and the
flyer that is also advertising seven
weeks of upcoming shows with other
headline okay that flyer he would have
liked me to promote write their entire
operation and I said yeah I think i
retweeted it he thought for a minute he
thought for a minute and then that was
apparently okay and he goes like this he
goes okay so I made it past him
so I go in I go into this [ __ ]
dungeon there I look around well we
can't do that now we have the video
everyone knows but I don't smoke and I
will say this we are sponsored by
Marlboro Lights Marlboro Lights they're
not just for Asians but Asians love them
and I think that's a smart EDM it is
they should do that I walk in this
lounge and I look around at everybody
that's there and it's it's it's clearly
people that are not they're not audience
they're all comedians and they're all
unwell you can see them it's just people
that are just starting
you're right they think this is their
mom right red it's not a cool mic it
ain't hit yeah tell these aren't the
kids who think these people are and then
I look at the woman who booked me and I
can just tell I look I take a quick look
at her and she's thrilled she smiling
everybody showed up was she's she's
theorem she's been a big so she's
thrilled she's happy and she's smiling
and I say oh she's a zombie
she's assumption now I gotta talk to
this Searles ahhmm be who was bitten by
the bug of delusion and everything else
so should I say where I go hi uh is this
an open mic like just lets Jesus she
goes no it's a book show she goes but
it's all comics in the audience and I'm
like that's a that's a mic but I don't
say that tonight you can because she's
been bit so I don't want her to bite me
I don't want whatever is infected her to
infect me that's why you can't
spend time with losers people think I'm
being mean when I say that know it you
catch it right you catch user yeah these
people yeah so then I see a girl that I
love who's a brilliant comic who's
sitting at the bar who's really good
who's had a rough go of it right and I
walk up to her I approach her carefully
because I don't know if she's been bit
either but it don't look good doesn't
look good doesn't look good right she
looks fine from the outside you can't
see the scales yeah I can't see the
bulging veins and the bluish skin you
can't see the vacant look in her eyes
and you can't see the blood dripping
from her mouth because she's just out of
fresh kill so so I see her sitting at
the bar and I'm like well she's she's
okay right I mean I knew her she looks
how she just looked when I knew her
right I walk over to her and I go hey
how are you and I say is this an open
mic and I swear to Christ she put her
hand on my shoulder and she looked at me
she goes honey we're in half and then
she goes you want to see the dresses I
bought and she opens a bag and starts
pulling out dresses which were
disgusting and I mean I'm not a
fashionista but they were like [ __ ]
Brown uh-huh they were not good yeah
this was not a rodeo spree
she was on these were probably dresses
of people who she bit and she's drinking
a milk glass of scotch and she then and
and then actually show me the dresses I
just back away slowly right back away
slowly yeah like you fight a gun I would
have the gun on everybody as I back away
like not make I'm looking there we're
not making eye contact
I finally get in an uber and I get the
[ __ ] out of there and then this con tu
booked me messages me on Instagram she's
like uh what about that other show I had
you booked on him like well what's the
deal with that one she looks two
different shows yeah because I still
she's like oh don't worry I already
booked it and then I wanted to go off on
her tell it what she was about right but
then I said Nana Nana Nana blocker
yes blocker yeah yeah get her out yeah
yeah Eric don't send her a message that
she's gonna then publicize these people
are like they're like mediums that talk
to ghosts except the ghost
are there shows and their career in
comedy people don't even be cannot even
begin to understand the human tragedy
that is comedy it's unbelievable most of
the shows there like pranks is this
jackass like what does color cameras
around I like to do this to me I don't
care where you work I don't care if you
work in a cancer ward of Sick Children
there is nothing sadder than what this
is I don't care if every day you have to
walk into a room and tell a bunch of
parents it's his last warning go on in
there and kiss him that is much more
uplifting yeah then dealing with the
fear oh yeah
zombies that walk the earth in hell it's
like we just saw this great play the
ferryman in New York City and man I wish
I had that quote from the Greek
mythology or something where the guy
goes and there's just these thousand
souls Hades won't even take him on the
river across to like owl or whatever
uh-huh there's these thousand souls they
just walked the earth
undead looking waiting for the ferryman
and I'm like oh [ __ ] I know them all
yeah I know those people I got him in my
phone and you gotta be nice but no it's
okay just I can't show up because of
this or that you can't just say like
you're an absolute sociopathic maniac
I'm not saying that I am [ __ ] you
know I like anything that should be
respected whatever I'm saying if you
have a show tonight I walked through
show to a four people that right and I
said we're not doing this right now
cousin they looked at me like I was
insane
right no see it doesn't matter who you
are it matters that you're a human being
that deserves human respect
yes Quinn and for whatever reason the
minute you say you do stand up people
are just like no it's okay you'll come
you do stand-up in my bathroom to my you
know I was in it right you come come do
stand-up in my bathroom Cody in the top
um I was in uber the other day going you
know taking another $70 uber I just
around I like the uber guy goes yeah in
the comedy business and I'm like because
I was talking to him on the phone
yeah yeah yeah I was it was you know I
always want to get in that older guy
older guy that white guy like you know
that you know like someone's fun uncle
who ain't that fun you know what I mean
yeah that guy
yeah and he's Akeno I always want again
it seems like it takes so much balls to
just get up there and as he says that I
just put my headphones in and I just
press play
I just went out I just stopped I said I
can't do it I can't even engage this guy
conversation about what an utter
nightmare I mean just and that's for his
own sake I mean you know like you would
just be so unbearably just he goes it's
got to take a lot when there's a lot of
people in the audience I said well
there's no one in the audience sir lucky
for you there's no one here everyone in
the audience wants to get on the stage
they're just waiting to get on the stage
yeah yeah it's a [ __ ] that's a bunch
of people making fliers and I was just
there yes and you know windows movie
maker they're making a really good flier
but the flyer yeah they put a movie
scene that they love that they couldn't
she do a fake show that never happens
and just make a big flaw is it a glossy
flyer there was a whole year in LA where
I just posted that I was on shows yeah
no one no I would just say like I'm on
laugh tub tonight 9:00 p.m. check it out
come I would cancel Mike's I bit Mike's
cancelled yeah I would not show up he'll
just have control it's all a farce it's
all insane it's completely they are
wandering the earth souls that can't get
into heaven or hell awaiting the
ferryman that just won the Tony for Best
Play that's what it is they are they are
just damaged it's not even cute it's
really not if you're not performing a
club it's embarrassing now yeah people
gone I'm having my four year anniversary
show and we're doing it in the back of a
truck and we're opening up the truck it
would do it's a pop-up show in the back
of a truck going down the 405 and it's
the four year anniversary I walk into
some of these shows I'm like you've been
doing this three years you're admitting
it and you're having an anniversary
how about yet get married and have an
anniversary with someone who loves you
right instead of inflicting your comedy
on a heap the worst is the road trips
that you see them and they post your
Facebook you know like just drove 37
hours
oh yeah finally in in you know upstate
New York
yeah for people in the crowd I did 70
minutes I just want to say to everyone
in this audience who's not pursued your
dream good for you you're like legends
you are you are the legends they're
amazing people you were the winner it's
just I took god the people that just
went and got their welders the way since
the winner is the person who unclog the
toilet and gets paid for it right that's
the wind the winner is not the person
who wanders around Los Angeles for 35
years trying to get it it's really it's
crazy and then the other half of it here
which I love is I have a few friends who
are connected to obscene wealth the kind
of wealth it's it doesn't even make
sense and it's so it's they're so rich
they're bored like have you met the
people that are so rich yeah they're
bored leave like they go on vacation
away from their vacation that is their
life essentially they have these they
have lots that are 18,000 square feet
houses that are 6500 square feet rooms
upon route no one's using any of these
rooms homeless people living in the
rooms they never met them yeah and they
just float in a pool all day and it's
boring
they have 10-foot hedges so nobody could
see them then there's all these like I
went to a one or two of these rooftop
pools and the ideas everyone being hot
here is like a movie that's a TV show
because I went to a few of these rooftop
holes there's fat chicks eating bowls of
ice cream yeah cuz that's the new thing
now that's that's what's hot now that
are hot yeah billboards and I've seen in
LA for a weed-like cush city or
something and they're all sponsored but
they're all it's a fat woman on every
single ad yeah like like sponsoring the
we gotta be near death right now yeah to
get any attention yeah
yes they don't think you're gonna
explode in the room they won't write a
check you gotta be fat like like like be
like not even like curvy anymore now cuz
then they get mad at you if they give a
curvy person like Amy Schumer a job
right they all go insane and go but she
can still walk on her own so she's not
really representing us yeah we want a
scooter [ __ ] yeah yeah in that movie
we're a girl that can't fit through a
subway turnstile that has to be rolled
around like Violet Beauregarde it's not
representation if she can breathe on her
own does she have a sleep apnea mask if
not it ain't representation we want
fatties not curvy not a few you throw
down a few chip witches I'm talking
about sitting alone in your apartment
drinking soda eating chips like dirty
white-trash fat like constantly farting
where you're never not fart right all
burning that's a level of fat you're
worth or walking is fueled by their
farts yeah like like a hot air balloon
that's just losing altitude
that's a type of woman we want
representing our brand they hydrate with
hollandaise vanities prints have
plus-size models and they get med than
the women aren't in a hospital right
you're not in an O or cuz you know
surgery's invasive shaming yeah Yeah
right
oh you can't you can't you know it's you
can't say anything about it you're
actually like an accessory to murder if
you don't yeah say it like if you're not
honest about somebody's unhealthy weight
yeah kind of aiding them and dying well
men even people that are succeeding
right now in this business and I say
this are people and myself is in one of
them people that should be in some form
of a group home like these are people
that shouldn't be allowed to plan their
own day they should have lost you look
at something you watch some people now
that have a show and you go that
person's like [ __ ] right right like
their brain is bouncing around in their
head yeah and then there's a bunch of
people making a lot of money watching
yeah yeah watching this person soar moly
eight right in front of their like
bearded ladies in the circus you know by
being weighted by a you know a network
but I mean other than other than that
he's been right well folks
I just we just I just had an argument
with my producer Ben and we screamed at
each other he didn't really scream but I
was yelling at him about a nonsensical
technical matter and I was very upset at
him and it's isn't there's no reason
that I was as upset as I was he kind of
he rolled his eyes at me and I said ask
something and then he said I have 12
podcasts like he had like he didn't care
about there so that this one didn't mean
anything to him I wasn't special
and me and I in Bennis trance and it's
something that that's why I hired him
and I said I don't want another
statistic right now cuz he could very I
could very easily just kill another
trans person and he would just be a
meaningless statistic and I don't want
that so we decided to make up I think I
threatened to music I'll destroy you he
produces another podcast for a lunatic
woman I'm like I'll take that from you
he was like what but I got me thinking
about better help folks
is there something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals is there yes if so
better help online counseling is here
for you better help offers licensed
professional counselors who's to say
they're not can you prove they're not
you can't prove that the text bubble on
the other side of that screen is not a
doctor I'm sure listen people have
actually used this people because my
audience needs help let's be honest
there you know my audience is what if
you know basically a few weeks out of
prison you know and they've actually
used this service and they like it
because they do have really good
counsellors that specialize in
depression stress anxiety relationships
sleeping anger which would have been
good for me and Ben it would just angry
at each other because we got into a
small like a clerical issue was not a
big deal but Ben was kind of being like
pouty so when you're good-looking what
happens is you act but you get pouty I
could never get pouty it's just not I
have to get angry because otherwise I'm
not I would look like a lunatic if if if
a person who's not good-looking or a
little bigger big frame big boned a
rotund individual its pouty they
you you you act and you look like you've
had a stroke or something's wrong but
when you're skinny or a better looking
you can kind of pout and you get like
very like I don't know like you're wrong
but I have to get angry and and and
start yelling and screaming because
that's the only way that I can process
emotion
whereas Ben can kind of get like well
you you just don't know it I go through
you know and then he just kind of paused
and he rolls his eyes you know so uh I'm
gonna better help folks you you this is
what you deal with with better help this
does he's looking at me now like this
doesn't this is exactly what this dad
should be you get angry at people why do
i why do i yell and scream when I'm
angry I don't know I don't know is it
cuz [ __ ] you know nobody in this
industry's ever helped me and if if I
had [ __ ] you know real [ __ ] balls
I'd go get a [ __ ] 8k and show up
somewhere and show everybody no I mean
I'm joking around kidding you know why I
don't do that you know I don't grab an
ak-47 and go down Melrose popping off
everyone because it better help okay
there's a better help calm slash Tim
Dylan you get 10% off your first month
okay I'm not gonna do anything crazy
because a better help I don't have time
to just sit down with an actual shrink
or a therapist but better help slash Tim
Dylan you get 10% off your first month
this is good
I've used this okay I've got a busy
schedule I'm a busy guy I got a lot
going on you know I I have at least
three hours of work a day to do and then
the rest of that is spent kind of
plotting and laying and converting you
know all the hatred and the bile bile
that's inside of me that that sludge
from ghostbusters it went through the
subway systems you know I got to get rid
of that I got to make it funny or get
rid of it so I go I'd go to better help
you know
the [ __ ] our girl with the coffee's
at the door
alright we're gonna let her in now but I
mean you know we made out we're fine now
everybody's good I hope I don't know you
never know what Ben cuz Ben could be
harboring you know he could be angry and
not then not let you know and because
he'll keep it in cuz he's not that
Christian [ __ ] they keep it in they
don't say anything's very
passive-aggressive they keep it all in
because they were raised Christian so
everybody's got to [ __ ] everybody's
gotta keep everything in and it's
everything's very dark and biblical and
they only let it out when they have to I
let it right out it comes right to the
top and it's done but battle ben'll hold
this against me for six years six years
so I better help everybody go to better
help
don't [ __ ] off other than that it's been
a real we've had a real time of it and I
show one of my friends showing these
guys from Long Island House I'm mad I'm
like just a beautiful house he this is
this is why people from Long Island is
just what you always gotta I always have
respect for them because there's a level
of stupidity that they have like it's
become like it's so innate to who they
are to try to educate them right would
be to completely destroy them yeah it
would be to completely cuz my friend
goes dad ain't that nice and I go okay
he goes with the bricks a [ __ ] up and
then in this beautiful huge backyard in
LA he zooms in on a few bricks on the
deck right it aren't even Italian guy he
was a bricklayer has known as bad I'm
like dude what is wrong with you
but this is the way that they did they
just look at everything you're like so
one right that ain't good yeah
I should have laid those bricks right
envy that bone away you know I envy that
that's great one of the ways and that's
why I took Ben out to Long Island when
he came in New York and he he kind of
got it immediately
because like one of the first things we
saw was a chevy suburban unlike what was
that thing on it was on like huge it was
like a monster truck that they had made
out of a Chevy Suburban completely
irrational
unreasonable no reason for it and just
it's there hmm it's there and the guy's
just driving like a psychopath mm-hmm
that's what these people are about they
don't give a [ __ ]
not at all and that's what this city's
lacking yeah a lack of giving a [ __ ]
well you know I don't know I look at
here and I'm like am I gonna be here 6
months 6 years 16 years I don't know I
can't know it's very interesting some of
my friends are worth so much money and
have done so well and you look at them
and you go that's a [ __ ] real
inspiration and then there's people I
know that have been bit and are fearow
and are wandering the streets waiting
for the ferryman and you go well
somewhere between those two I hope to
carve out a little niche for myself what
what were you doing in Dallas do you
like Dallas no I mean it's it's nice
it's setup for people that have made it
you know they got money and it's just
everyone is just there looking forward
to their next meal after yeah well the
people of Dallas state whether they have
money or not they're going out and
eating steak you're in a suit no no yeah
it's very nice but it's like it's like
you know even the young people is like
are you retired you're like 28 like this
is what you just let's a Long Island
everybody in Long Island like their
musical tastes or their parents right
there's like there's like 17 year old
that are like I like Billy Joel Billy
Joel's great but like why don't you go
and get something that your parents
don't approve of right Seema's Larkin
politics everybody gets a house because
their mother starts showing signs of
cancer right and instead of taking her
the doctor and getting her better yeah
wait yeah you just wait you [ __ ] on your
hands but listen to her voice and every
day it gets a little weaker and then one
day she goes everything's fine and then
she falls down the stairs one day
and you you look at her and you wait so
she stops breathing and they call the
ambulance
yeah and then she's dead
Harrod her house and immediately while
her body is still warm you start
bitching about all the taxes you have to
pay on the house that you [ __ ]
inherited you're like I these taxes are
ridiculous I'm paying for everything
here and you're 40 years old you barely
had a job and you're just waiting for
your mother to croak yeah well that's
how they get the [ __ ] let's how they
get the houses I would I can't wait till
we do this we're doing this thing you
know we have wicks as a sponsor we're
doing this thing where we're allowing
people to call in and have upgraded
their sites using my site which is Tim
Dylan's going to hell calm no is Tim
Dylan's DLL ons so there's a few and one
guy I sent me a message today DME goes
hey I'm getting my business idea ready
can you buy me a week or two before I'm
definitely gonna do the wick site but I
don't have my business idea ready to go
on your show yet um and I said well
we're not we're probably not doing it
for another week but I'm thinking in my
head I'm like you know this guy has no
idea right and he's just [ __ ] around
and he's gonna call in here and he's
gonna tell us an idea that's already a
thing yeah tell us an idea that's
already a fully operational business
yeah you know he's like I need a while
to get my business idea ready I'm like
it's god help us it'll be GrubHub it'll
be something that's already functional I
mean what what are you like if you're uh
if you're a tech guy now what are you
what's the next what's left yeah what is
laughs what is left I really don't know
it's just like apps for I think once
they legalized prostitution that's
common that'll be good that'll be coming
there will be that'll be common old
rough I want to go on a grub hub and
just pick a dick yeah right and then
just go you know I think that's gonna be
the next me the next thing that'll be
the next a they haven't already ready
they're just waiting for like a law to
get past and then they just drop the
hammer of the road you made a good point
he's like there's all these in sales
legalized prostitution right just
legalized prostitution cut out the
shootings eventually and then
Julie what I think you'll start to see
is you will start to see like the
there's all these weird creepy like Elon
Musk owns a bunch of these companies I
think one is called neural link where
it's literally about just you know
implanting like it's merging biology
with AI it's essentially merging it's
like Elon Musk you said we gotta merge
with technology so that AI doesn't
destroy us we have to merge with it or
they're gonna destroy us because we've
already opened the can of worms and it
is what it is and as soon as a I can
just read they can read every book
that's ever been written an instant
they're gonna be smarter than us they'll
be smarter than Jordan Peterson they'll
be smarter than everybody mm-hmm and
then they're gonna come and they're
gonna look at us like bugs and they'll
probably get rid o just get rid of us if
we stand in their way see Allah mask is
like what we have to do is merge with
them right
and the government's been studying all
these things like the Penta is he's
thing called DARPA which is the defense
I don't know ever gonna say it right but
it's like the defense agency read the
defense agency Research Projects
administration or something of that and
they study weapon systems in the future
and they're that the book on it was
written by Annie Jacobson who's uh she
just went on Rogan and I know we're a
little because her son is friends with
my friend's son and I tried to get her
on my show but she's too busy for that
and she's got a she talks like a
stripper and she's like Josh she's
talking about mommy's actually in area
51 it's really wet it's really wet and
it's wet because and it's like she's a
phone sex operator with a brain of OHS
for UFOs
so she wrote a book and she was
basically like listen these guys are 20
years ahead all the technology that we
have 20 years ago they had this so they
had some version of it right and that
they have things that are so 20 years
from now is terrifying and she said some
of the things that they're working on
are these neural links neural interface
programs where you can order drone
strikes with your head because it's too
much time to order them with your finger
cuz there's a
at the liberation right doesn't it seem
like that yeah when we're just bomb and
weddings and poor kids playing soccer
and Pakistan it's it's apparently too
hard to level villages right so what we
need to do is have basically some chip
in someone's head so they could just
think about a drone strike and then
it'll just start to light the world on
fire so that's that's on its way me and
Ben we're watching our drone strikes the
other day it's important by the way it's
important if you if you feeling
patriotic yeah at any point go and watch
a drone struck go watch a death machine
fly across the air and kill probably an
innocent child yeah and really get an
idea what and the idea that like and by
the way these people have never even
seen this technology it would be the
equivalent of us having UFOs come here
and just vaporize right right
they're out there and would you and and
you start to realize that like Isis was
never a threat all of the idea that
these people are threats is a complete
[ __ ] lie these people are in caves
have wanted them we fund them we make
them if wall said they're improv team
that's what we do that's exactly what we
do yeah okay so pretend that you're
let's say you were gonna attack a
country which it may be you do it with
this weapon this is a prop it's Bill
Hicks joke you know you give the guy a
you know you give it's like that Jack
Palance in the movie Shane right right
you give the guy a gun and you're like
look at ya look at him he had a gun yeah
but it's like you watch those drone
strikes and you say to yourself it's
hard to take any politician seriously
that gets on TV and starts talking about
Isis or any of these you could just
vaporize and you only have to get to
that level which is the most depressing
part because they all start off like in
this time or they gone Rogen they sound
like oh man like grass roots like yeah
it's gonna be they're gonna they're like
real it's a real person yeah can I keep
going a year goes by the campaign then
they're talking about all this [ __ ]
they're working yeah
you got bit yeah well yeah well what I
think the reality is that one of the two
things is a show right
so it's either Obama coming out before
he gets into office saying I think that
we've gone a little too far in Iraq
right which is what needed to happen
nobody would have won if a guy was like
listen the problem is we need more at
that point the country was like wait
wait hold on wait a minute
you needed a guy who was cerebral and
articulate to go out there go
yeah there's limits to what the American
military could do so then what they did
was just quietly drone strike people
quietly George liked people and then he
you know went on Ellen and danced
so all these idiot blue check marks out
here were like yeah scran they were like
oh he's great and and and and so you say
to yourself you're like well which is
the real guy and then it's more
complicated than that I'm sure and I'm
sure it's not as easy and I'm sure when
you get in there the CIA all these
people cuz I know because I've read
books and I've had people on the show
they start telling you all these things
that you need to do because we're in
where we're in because they they they
basically go in there and go the
presidential daily briefing the threat
assessment which Trump by the way was
like I don't need it Thanks keep moving
but that is really to just go in there
and terrify right who's ever the
president they just terrifying
yeah and they go we heard that a guy was
gonna blow up the Sears Tower just
because some raving lunatic miker and
Beirut is running around talking
nonsense and they present it to the
president like it's an actionable piece
of information right well they're like
well any day now that so you just better
authorize whatever the [ __ ] we have to
do and and and this is why it's like
it's hard to take anybody [ __ ]
seriously when they go out there any of
these politicians and they start talking
about you know the great threats and
da-da-da-da-da and yeah it's like you
know it's like a I feel like now it's
like a the country's like a like a madla
like they fill in the blanks for what
they know we want to hear now cuz
they're hip enough to it cuz there's
like oh the people okay now I know what
they want
I'm not gonna come off all right and
dumb like at the 8th yeah and he's like
just out of touch right I'm gonna say
what they want to hear but then when I'm
in I'll just do what the [ __ ] they tell
me to do yeah because that's what we did
all the threats are internal yeah let's
be honest yeah it's the the opium I mean
the the opioid epidemic you have you
know yeah we focus on any of that when I
focusing on that we have we have people
eating food with plastic in it pretty
much like we have we have people turning
on the faucet and like purple water's
coming out brown water [ __ ] colored
waters coming out you know we have a
health care system where I mean I love
this tweet where the guy goes they go
isn't this great Home Depot they tweet
outs of a Home Depot they go
is it a greatest they didn't know if
this his health care company would cover
a walker for this three-year-old so Home
Depot made him one Home Depot when got
some scraps from the parking lot and
made a walker for this three-year-old
cuz his parents talked to the health
care company and health care companies
like well I don't know we got to figure
this out but why don't you carry them so
so they just fashioned a walker out of
scraps right in Home Depot and this poor
kid is so I mean it's like I mean it is
an evil yeah system it's a bad bad
system right out there and and then you
ask like you know Ben Shapiro on those
guys they're like wow you know start a
hedge fund mm-hmm what about how about
dark why don't you do some currency
arbitrage why didn't the family why
didn't the family think about that right
why didn't the family incorporate
themselves and start buying real estate
flipping prop like you know it's like
the utter callousness yeah of people and
I'm not even that like I'm not a
left-wing guy I'm not a right-wing guy
I'm just a guy that looks at things and
goes we're beyond Fox right and how like
I don't think it's helpful that now if
if if if a seventeen-year-old comes up
to me goes by the way uh I'm from
another planet and you go wait what they
go you're a Nazi right that's not
helpful yeah that's not helpful it
became a little dangerous when you were
considered like punk rock too
think there's like two genders right
that day came I was like wait what
you're like a bad guy yeah no there's
like men and there's women and they're
like wow there's no logical prey there's
no rational logical person that when you
say to them there's actually an
innumerable amount of genders nobody
believes that no people are either
terrified into opening their mouths
there's not a human being on earth that
did that make sense to okay nobody even
the person saying that they're offended
that purse has been bitten here oh
there's a lot of people that have been
bit that's the problem you look at them
because they do your fear oh yeah
put your letters right to the right you
have people talking about race and IQ
and we're gonna there needs to be an
ethnos state and we're gonna and you go
oh your fear oh yeah you got bit right
and then the New York Times writes this
article where they're like well people
went down a YouTube rabbit hole and
ended up radicalized right to the right
which is easy to do according to the New
York Times and listen I get it
it's eat you can get records a lot of
people are on YouTube going why does my
life suck or some of them are just bored
so they just go and they start here and
then they end up somewhere in the nether
region to the internet watching David
Duke right or whatever but then you also
got to realize that happens to the left
yeah
the newer times acts like there's no
such thing as left-wing extremism and
then go on tumblr and there's somebody
that's identifying as a cat yeah well
that person was radicalized by something
right people that are calling themselves
other kin I'm a fairy I'm a pixie I'm a
pansexual queer identifying demi-plié
like this is both sides completely yes
salon.com thank you here you talking
about feral bench burros like a house
cat like he's young in the same way
where he's like black people like why do
they have so much black about crime is
like you're from Sherman Oaks you've
never lived anywhere but Sherman Oaks
right met a black person three times and
it's olives candy so yeah but that's the
thing and you have to now deal with
rabid zombies like they're people mm-hmm
and that's because everybody has a place
at the table so somebody saddles up to
the table and starts spouting craziness
and you have to sit there and go oh
right really when did you first realize
that you were a woman in the morning but
then a man for lunch and then uh or when
did you realize that gender fluidity was
the thing
well what article did you read were you
self diagnosed yourself as being gender
fluid I'm not saying that there aren't
legitimate cases of people that don't
identify as either gender okay that's
fine but you get one [ __ ] designation
right one thing yeah you don't get an
innumerable amount of [ __ ] things
that's it you you you you okay I'm
non-binary good then that's it you can't
be 5,000 different make-believe genders
that you've come up with cuz you read
The Chronicles of Narnia and you want to
be a faun these are all nerds I mean me
and Malin talked about it yeah there's a
lot of nerds in the trans community oh
yeah real big nerds yeah I have a hell
of respect for like trend real
transvestites and transsexuals Brian so
got the clubs and have fun and do coke
and fight each other on the streets and
Greenwich Village yeah beat the [ __ ] out
of each other on the C train yeah I
don't think these these [ __ ] are
nerds now hormonal geek squad they're
nerds yeah if [ __ ] Lord of the Rings
has become the new like [ __ ] is weird
like Game of Thrones [ __ ] what is
this what kind of training are you
well actually Westeros I mean it's like
wait a minute what right we've made
[ __ ] into people are really like
kind of incapable at this point of
holding two conflicting ideas in their
head which I've always thought was the
basis of just like a normal intelligent
person which I can't use everything so I
have to just kind of look at in the
middle and there's nobody that I've ever
liked in my life that I didn't also want
to kill right that is the thing that you
have to remember there's not one person
I've ever truly loved and appreciated
that I didn't want to kill I imagined my
close friends getting into car accidents
as I go to bed I am
imagine them taking their last breath
and I love them I love them more than
anything but to me if you don't feel
that way if you don't understand duality
you're not covering all babies you gotta
understand yeah deep like I'm staying
right now in LA at a house that my crazy
friend is I'm paying rent to stay there
and it's kind of there's a sadness
because her family's kind of dissolving
but at the same time there's an
opportunity for me in the the
dissolution of her family unit right so
I have to go there and cannibalize the
last bits of life of that family and I
don't like that right but hey baby what
are you gonna do they came to me and ago
where we don't really kind of want to be
a family anymore
so can you live here with this fat cat
and I said yeah it doesn't mean I'm
thrilled about the circumstances right
but this is what it is there's two
things happening simultaneously
you know like inheriting money from a
family member that you loved that died
yeah add about that you're like oh but
also like I'm showing up to the funeral
now and and that's what pisses my heart
Saghir I could see all these people -
all you want to eat the rich you hate
the rich but only because a lot of in
many cases you want to be the rich
mm-hmm I'm not talking about people that
have principled arguments like you know
the three-year-old with the [ __ ]
Walker this is disgusting I'm talking
about the people who are also rich but
not rich enough right not famous enough
it's never enough and everything that
they do and say is just to kind of get
them to that next yeah level and they
admit it they go on stage they bet it
they'll I can't eat the rich but you
know I'd love to hang out with you yeah
tweeting their outrage of billionaires
from their Tesla on their way to their
[ __ ] $500,000 your writing job they
just they just want to be famous which
is okay but admit it I want an audience
I want people
appreciate what I do I'm good at being
funny I'm not good at solving problems
I'm good at solving problems in my own
life to an extent but not even that good
at it right but I'm never gonna look at
a group of people that came to see me in
a theater and say you know why we did
this tonight folks do you know why we
did it tonight for the poor we did it
for them that's why I got on the stage
and told jokes and made all this money
for the poor for people that are [ __ ]
that's why I did this yeah what I would
say is it like hey I'm doing this cuz
it's what I'm good at
hopefully you enjoyed it and this will
not be pieces of [ __ ] and let's try to
help people when we can but to disguise
my career as like it's this altruistic
thing like me having a television show
is a difference between the the sick and
destitute right getting what they need
to get would make me a [ __ ] crazy
person yep
that would make me fear all mm-hmm that
would mean I had been bit I try not to
get bit it's hard here hard to not get
bit cuz that's what people when you hear
people talk out here they're really like
you know what would really help the
world is if I got yeah I got in a movie
right if people could just hear that I'm
Dominican yeah world peace would would
happen yeah I think all the problems in
the world would end if people found out
that I'm gay yeah right well now I'm
gonna go into meetings and when they're
like mr. Dhillon I'm gonna say excuse me
oh no it's miss it is miss Dillon and
I'll wait for the check thank you I'll
wait for the check is my career I want
to sit down my agents today and say my
career I want to sit down today at my
agency with all these rich [ __ ]
people and they're sitting there on the
table and I got I want all of you to
know that my career is about lifting up
marginalized voices and it's about
ending world hunger yeah okay so when
you go back to your desk today don't
think hey this fat guy just wants more
money to stuff poky in his face that
ain't it that ain't it that ain't it at
all I want you to go back to
can go this gentleman wants to solve
world hunger and the Middle East I want
to stop my career right now is about
solving the israeli-palestinian issue
yes right where everyone is happy that's
why that's my next special right my next
special is about that issue now what
have any material about that issue
you're gonna have to take my word for it
you really are gonna have to take my
word for it I just don't I don't really
have a lot of material on that issue
yeah but it's about making people feel
safe yeah that's my career right it's
about safety folks I'm gonna tell you
right now I love Prem essent I love it
it's perfect for any man that wants to
last longer in bed okay it's great
let's be honest majority of men do not
last long enough for their partner to
have an orgasm and some of them care
about that but they do on average men
take five and a half minutes to reach
climax where women take around 18
minutes well that's absurd that's a very
18 minutes a very long time
you know but men are out of there in
five women lasts for 20 what is the
solution is it better sex is it a better
partner no it is premise it and it is a
spray spray pre messing on your deck and
you'll be left with next normal
sensitivity and usually have stronger
orgasms for the prolonged build-up to
climax how cool is this firm s it is
recommended by over 2200 urologists okay
well I thought we're concerned with
other things like you know uh you know
prostate cancer but apparently they're
not they're testing dick sprays in strip
malls in Arizona the 2200 urologists are
are all in for promising it's also the
number one sexual enhancer product on
Amazon okay so it probably works it
really works and it's it's important to
last long in bed you know and you don't
want to get involved with the pills
except are less they have blue chew as a
pill so that's also good
that's a chewable but you don't want to
start swallowing pills
unless cialis gives me some money and
then I'll [ __ ] I'll go to bat for
cialis cuz those [ __ ] they got
some cash you know you know I'm dealing
with companies here that run out of
people's trucks you know the
headquarters this is in a Tahoe but I'm
kidding it's a joke folks a comedy
podcast it's a great company sprayed on
your [ __ ] and go longer in bed okay
delay spray calm what a [ __ ] site go
to delay spray calm and if you use the
promo code Tim 15 you'll get another 15
percent off your purchase okay delay
spray com it's actually a good idea
to do that you know
I truly believe
that this is the move spraying on your
deck spray it on your deck can you
believe that these are the products that
we advertise here like there's no we
can't get anything else we can't get
blue apron you know I can't get into it
QuickBooks every every other product is
about sprang something on your dick or
like you know eating a CBD putting CBD
on your cheeseburger so that you can go
to sleep I mean what do they think of
this audience what are the ad people
think of this audience you know I mean
what what are we gonna be advertising
next you know could it get worse good to
picture the audience get more pathetic
with the ads hey can you not [ __ ] do you
lay in bed anxious because your life is
a hell
how about CBD and and spray on your [ __ ]
do you want to kill yourself how about
this online counseling service was there
a study done of our audience where
they're like well they all can't [ __ ]
they're anxious and want to kill
themselves but they also can't leave
their houses because they can't afford
lubbers to go to therapy so we have a
online counseling service Spray [ __ ]
spray and and [ __ ] CBD and wicks
because they only [ __ ] website still
they all need websites they got nothing
else going on they need a website you
know what they need a family that's what
they need they need a family premiss it
folks
what's that promo code again it's great
great where is it here it is delay spray
com promo code Tim 15 you'll get 15% off
your purchase so before you open your
mouth and slide the Glock into it go to
delay spray calm promo code Tim 15 folks
wicks wicks what can I say about wicks
other than this is the last out of the
[ __ ] episode you know many of you are
out there without a clue in life and
that's imagine I imagine that's why
we've connected on whatever level
and I've told you week after week to to
get a website and and and Wix is the
best way to do it if you don't have a
lot of money many of you do not have a
lot of money and the money you have you
need to spend on dick pills and CBD you
cannot invest it in yourself so you only
have a small budget for things like Wix
okay Wix is perfect they have over 500
distinct templates then avi Wix
artificial design intelligence you can
answer a few questions about what you
want the website to be an AI bots will
design the website for you okay they'll
design the website for you so you don't
have to do anything you can just sit
back and wait for the money train to
roll in with your great idea or your art
that needs to get out there you need to
get your fatah you need to get your
wedding photography out there
how about Wix you get a website show
everybody you're a good photographer at
the wedding
you there won't be a minute of joy
wasted at that wedding
look at Aunt Sheila dance put that on
the Wix website where's aunt Sheila now
she's no longer with us
but you remember aunt Sheila the way she
was at that wedding drunk dancing sang
en word in a Long Island catering hall
that look like a Little Caesars Palace
I'm disgusting [ __ ] all that you got
your whole the whole fire department
came out tea penne alla vodka I danced a
Sweet Caroline and and you great
photographer read copies of some of
these stories used to make me laugh and
that's what you do you put your photos
of those happy people on your Wix
website and what happens they call you
the morones Collier and the Benedetto's
and the O'Leary's and they go we saw
your website on WIC [ __ ] we need a
photographer for wedding in my daughter
met you up okay he's and they look and
it seals the [ __ ] deal because you
got a
website cuz you're a real man or woman
and you take your business seriously
it's not only Instagram you're not
getting the older people on Instagram
the boomers are not on social media as
much they're on Facebook they love it
cuz it's a website they want to go to
your site
boomers level website they can scroll
they just learned how to scroll they
like to scroll in a percocet haze look
at all look at all the [ __ ] get done
look at everything that you're about how
does he ever buy oh yeah you tell him
where you grew up
will you learned how to be a [ __ ]
wedding photographer you capture the
moments you go I capture the moments
don't believe me here are the moments um
so if you go to Tim Dillon's DLL ons
going to help calm not is there's no is
it's just Tim Dylan's
going to hell calm that is the Wix
website created for the show go to the
bottom of that website click on the link
that takes you to Wix upgrade your site
we are doing and this is the last week
we're mentioning because we're doing
this episode next week so if you don't
do in the next [ __ ] couple of days
don't even talk to me send me a
confirmation that you've done this you
will get 90 seconds on this show you'll
get three minutes on my show to promote
your idea in front of tens of thousands
of people whatever your business idea is
whatever your art is your band we got a
band that's on pour right now they're
gonna call in there's some other people
that are gonna call in there's a fashion
a very trendy black woman who's got a
beautiful fashion line on Instagram
she's gonna call in I hope she knows who
she's promoting it to leave my [ __ ]
dirtbags can afford what she's got she's
got a real trendy [ __ ] going on there I
looked very nice clothing okay I don't
know who's I don't know I'm broadcasting
to you but I can't imagine it's very
fashionable people it's probably a
family of possums that's what I believe
my audience is a family of possums okay
I know who's out there
so go to Tim Dylan's going to hell calm
click on the link and and really build a
website folks you get it you're gonna
love it's gonna change your life you got
a little deli you want to start a deli
well it better have a website that deli
better I've a website you could do
everything with a Wix website you can
link to social media I think you could
take orders through I don't know maybe
not
you know folks go go read their Terms of
Service
see what you can do over there but I
think you can do a lot of [ __ ] it's
great if you're just starting out many
of you are just starting out and
finishing but you don't know it yet you
don't know it yet you think it's all
gonna happen it ain't okay but let me
tell you you know it's comforting
what's nice to have while it's not
happening you have a site you have a
website because you think that someone's
gonna go to it one day and your life's
gonna change and for some of you that
might happen but for the majority of you
it'll be a slow gradual descent into a
pit of hell that is indescribable it's
indescribable really really I mean I
couldn't even begin to describe the
level of indifference that most people
will have to whatever you want to do
because most of you are not good enough
you're not smart enough sharp enough
strong enough and those of you who are
are riddled with doubt anxiety and fear
and that will destroy you
that being said Tim Dylan's going to
hell calm click on the link start your
own [ __ ] website don't don't don't
[ __ ] with me on this please do it thank
you
that's why everybody that's other thing
that loses me and people start talking
about safety like I don't feel safe it's
the safest it's ever been yeah crime
rates have dropped to a point where you
feel like a YouTube videos making you
feel unsafe in the 70s you would walk
down the street New York City people
were cooking bodies there were like
roasting bodies on a rotisserie like you
were in Boston Marcus so nowadays Travis
Bickle is doing a show on YouTube on a
webcam that's and people are like he is
like you know we got a deep platform ham
laugh form him I'm scared I'm scared of
somebody tweeted at me I'm scared yeah a
hack did a juggler all up I'm gonna SWAT
myself I'm trying to swat my side Cole
that's
team and go get over here I'm kidding
that's why I never live in an address
that I ever because you can't swap me
he'll just SWAT another family that I'm
living with quite frankly and that's
their responsibility and they'll handle
it you put a gun in somebody's face it
ain't me I won't be there I we broadcast
from undisclosed locations I'm like Alex
Jones you don't know where I am right
now no you don't know where Alex is
broadcasting from I don't know where I
am I mean how does it what about the
Pride Parade we did you celebrate did
you go to Dallas pride now no I don't
think I don't think I think they might
have banned it in Dallas I don't know
they're like oh you don't go to the
Pride Parade
you didn't go to appropriate I've been a
pride advance it before the pride comedy
shows yeah I'm sober it seems like an
environment that's fuelled with drugs
and alcohol I don't know if but I'm
guessing I drove through the Pride
Parade once in West Hollywood there's a
lot of gay people obviously West
Hollywood but I also sensed a lot of
guys there were just straight dudes
trying to capitalize on it's also like
can I just suck dick in my room what can
I be that kind of gay where I suck dick
in my room is that part of it anymore
yeah is sex even part of it right he's
[ __ ] does somebody have the same
gender even part of it right or do I
have to wrap myself in a cloak and dance
around like and say these people have
the people pride aren't even [ __ ]
right they're not even gay like you said
yeah it's also happening in places where
it's like yeah we're okay with gay
people do the Pride Parade in Birmingham
Alabama really make a change or
something like the tie Rivera's high
Rivera is a very funny guy who performs
all over the country yeah and he goes
into places their hostel together yeah I
used to do and he's bad [ __ ] balls
and he goes out and he takes his jokes
and he says here people that might not
accept my lifestyle you're gonna find me
[ __ ] funny and I'm not lecturing you
and I'm not gonna moralize but I bet you
leave here with more respect for gay
people because one of them just [ __ ]
entertain you for an hour all right so
of course the industry doesn't give a
[ __ ] about him okay yeah they like the
people that are dancing around and Wes
Farley well my heart
nobody cats in West Hollywood effects
nobody is impressed performing in New
York in LA some straight men here again
me yeah yeah do you know how many
straight men i could rape Jane
they wouldn't even say anything yeah
they would just sit to me like okay the
hot women are with them they don't to
deal with them they never touch them
right it's harder to go into places
where they don't like gay people listen
here's also the problem why is there a
ten-year-old dancing aunt this kid
Desmond the amazing have you seen this
no there's a ten-year-old kid or a left
and he's dancing on a bar he's at one of
the drag kids and he's dancing on a bar
and the people are throwing money in him
and listen man this is not good and I've
talked to a lot of gay people who are
older and people are like what the [ __ ]
is going on that's not and by the way
it's the same gay people that are like
why are there 400 Chandhok cuz you got
to realize at a certain point a lot of
the transient and gay [ __ ]
but bat bat heads right because I'm
attracted to dude so if you're a woman
and go I'm a dude I'm it's still not
working it doesn't matter right it's
like if you're attracted to really hot
guys and I tell you I'm thin I identify
his thin I identify as a volleyball
champion right people go I don't give a
[ __ ] yeah because I see what I see it's
real yeah so to me the section it's just
weird
it's kid it's just some no there there's
something deeply wrong
oh no he said he was he said he's a girl
for a few weeks in a row so we had to do
have no proper measures and get him
woman therapy if your kid has gender
problems number one iiiii say empathize
to an extent with being different but
here's the deal you cannot inject kids
with [ __ ] hormones that's just before
there are 18 years look this is child
abuse
literally it is and in realities you
cannot have a kid on a [ __ ] bar
that's a alcohol you're allowed in bars
in a sexual way and does he even know
what sex is do this for money then
because there's a lot of guys and I
talked to her in the closet
yeah and will probably remain so because
they don't they're like well I don't
want to co-sign this right
and I don't want to co-sign it either
right I'm like what the [ __ ] I wake up
some days and I'm like what the [ __ ] is
going on right why is there a
ten-year-old kid on a bar dancing who is
okay with this who are this kid's
parents right and then everybody
celebrating is on Good Morning America
like this right now I'm not against if
you if that kid wants to be in a dance
class and you have a boy that wants a
dance with up to it little bit of ballet
classes and then he'll find out he's gay
when he's 6 my parents put me in dance
classes because I was a professional
[ __ ] actor by the way and it was part
of what I had to do and I danced around
right it's fine that's not a thing
the problem is being in a bar and having
dudes throw money at you is is sick and
and I don't know why and there's a lot
of people gay straight and otherwise you
know kind of uncomfortable with this
[ __ ] yeah yeah and it kind of hurts all
the progress that you guys just made
just to be allowed to be gay it's it's a
it's a problem and when you try to have
discussions with people they go oh
you're self-hating gay guy or you're
there so your dad or you're not really
gay or you don't really I did you don't
get it I'm like no no no I get it
what I also get is that this really sets
any movement back because people are
looking at this [ __ ] and they're going
this is [ __ ] wild yeah and it's wrong
it is and this is gonna be drugged out
by the time he's 14 or 15 years old and
I just don't and so that it becomes a
problem and I have no issue you can you
know pride events are great in people
but listen if you want to wear a
g-string and do all that stuff that's
not every gay guy and the media loves
that it thinks it is and everybody likes
it it is and there's all these gay guys
it'll go out and be like well if you
don't embrace that and you're not really
gay and it's crazy really crazy it's
like telling somebody that like if they
don't conform to every stereotype
they're not really above you know you're
not a black guy you know you play ball
rapper yeah you're not black yeah you're
like wait a minute you know yeah it
becomes a problem and it's like it's
hard to have these conversations with
people right because you get accused of
all these things but it's
like no this is not okay this is a
[ __ ] problem the kitchen it's just
that's I when I was a kid I wanted to be
a cowboy I was obsessed with John Wayne
movies loved cowboys imagine if my
parents were like well we have to
respect this and they took me to the
desert put me on a horse and left me
alone I'm sure that is going on
somewhere I'm sure we're Ben grew up in
Texas that shit's going on they're like
our sons a cowboy they give him a real
bride and give him a horse give you a
real gun and then the kid decides the
saloon is the lunchroom at school and he
walks in he kicks open the doors and he
goes guess what I'm wider and then
everybody goes down in a hail of bullets
which I am against I'm against school
shootings and I have said that I have
come out and I said that and I don't
know why people have kind of twisted it
and made me there I've said that I'm
against you after school shoot you
denounced it no I know I am against
school shooting I've said we got to rein
in the guns everybody can't have an
ak-47 she just can't happen no I know
people want it but here's the deal folks
you don't want freedom you say you do
you really don't you don't care that the
government reads your mail you don't
give a [ __ ] that the government kidnaps
people tortures them waves their right
to a trial you don't care about who gets
Miranda right I don't care that they're
selling black kids you don't care that
there's private treasure is being sold
in Libya the only thing you really care
about is that you can have an Uzi that's
the only freedom you want to retain is
that you can have an ak-47 because in
your Star Wars fantasy that's how you're
gonna defeat Nancy Pelosi right and it's
just like if you care if this was a
really freedom-loving country where
people like we really want freedom and
there were riots in the streets and when
they opened Gitmo and when they passed a
Homeland Security Act people like this
is [ __ ] insane yeah when they started
prosecuting whistleblowers and torturing
them if people gave a [ __ ] about any of
that I would take the second amendment
purists a lot more seriously but they
don't seem to care about any of that
they love the cops all these people that
love guns I love the police they love
cops they love them kicking in your door
they love them shooting your dog in the
face because you got a little weed in
your fridge they
want [ __ ] they don't mind [ __ ]
beatin fifteen-year-old kids that walk
down the wrong Street
they love the police they love security
they love their gated communities and
they love that the cops are going out
there putting guns in black people's
faces they don't really give a [ __ ]
about that they just want to make sure
that they can have a small Arsenal in
their home that's the only thing they
really give a [ __ ] about they don't care
well good read my mail what is it what
does it matter read my mail compiled a
list of people that are critical the
government good yeah that's good that's
good compiled a list of people that said
questionable things online that sounds
good
now fly those death machines in other
countries and blow up kids blow arms and
legs off Pakistani kids I don't care
I've never met him I just want I just
want my guns you don't give a [ __ ] about
freedom this is the thing you don't so I
would take you seriously if you did but
you really don't no one gives a [ __ ]
Edward Snowden was run out of the
country Chelsea Manning who is annoying
on Twitter but still they locked Chelsea
Manning this girl they locked her in a
room and she lived in eight tortures and
what was her crime she said by the way
we're blowing off civilians heads right
she leaked that information she goes by
the way you know we're really doing over
here
and they locked her in a cage Obama the
good guy yeah they locked her in a cage
and you know what people did they did
nothing they didn't care they didn't
care where was the right wing then where
was all these gun nuts right then when
we're having a moral compass yeah when
she lost her freedom then nobody really
gives a [ __ ] now because I see all these
people that are all you know that
freedom and they're gonna take my free
you don't have any free no one's taking
the freedoms you don't have you have
freedom to get in your car and drive to
jack-in-the-box and that's all you want
that's what people say freedom is you're
like I can good in my car and go and go
down Ponderosa and get myself a t-bone
right and then go in your backyard and
shoot squirrels or whatever the [ __ ]
you're doing but
this whole idea of freedom the corporate
state and this is where this is what I
think it'll be people that are like
listening in their cars and everything
and and like their look they're kind of
looking at their their check or they're
looking at their friends and they're
kind of like yeah I don't the other
episode I don't know
I don't know the other episode he talked
about his Christmas dinner it was he
just [ __ ] on that that was that was
funny but I don't I don't really know
where all this is coming from and it's
coming from that I perform for for
[ __ ] people in the deli today so
someone's got to get it I know who's
getting it now the corporate state I'm
giving it to them I'm giving it to them
as I've given it to the military
industrial complex mm-hmm but people
think they've people these people have
won in a way that it's like you know I
mean we organized marches and
revolutions on phones we know were made
by slaves it's like what's it's oh you
don't even organized Martin I said the
other day on his podcast I said I said
this is a joke I said if you were
serious you'd strap a bomb to a toddler
and send one into a busy train station
every week and blow it up and I'm never
I don't advocate violence and I'm I will
never because I'm a comedian and I think
violence is abhorrent right but I can't
pretend if we're gonna have an
intellectual discussion I can't pretend
to ignore the idea that you're not gonna
really get MA you're not gonna get the
attention you want without a little bit
of you know I mean this is the reality
yeah you know you got a or you got a
mass demonstrations you got a millions
and millions of people in the street but
it's not gonna happen it's never you're
never gonna get millions of millions of
people in this country to walk into the
street and shut that they're not you
just not you know because we're not a
country we're a collection of loosely
affiliated the streets are empty if Game
of Thrones is having a finale yeah no
one's everyone's at home why we'd all
feel stupid
we don't feel dumb going and I'd feel
dumb like I'm suggesting this and I'd
feel so stupid
going to this cuz then you get there and
you turn around and some person you
hates there yeah like I don't I don't
yeah I know I don't I don't want to be
associated with this clown yeah and
we're all chanting in front of the White
House and I'm like I look over and I see
some I see some this more on the book to
me on the open mic and I go oh I don't
want her to live right why am I on her
side yeah we're never gonna come
together so it's like all you can really
do in this society all you can really do
to be honest with you is support my
career because my career is the answer
yeah I've learned that I've been in LA
only a week and I've really learned that
like all we can do is just help Tim
Dylan cuz if I get famous if I'm really
famous I was like a big house and I live
in Hollywood Hills and I have a big pool
I'm gonna swim in it but but hear me out
but hear me out don't don't [ __ ]
don't throw the baby out with the
bathwater let me tell you what else
every now and then I'm gonna go to a
dinner I'm gonna write a check and I'm
gonna give that cheque to a company that
will take 98% of that for their
operating expenses and then distribute
2% of that they'll go and they'll hand
the guy a new pair of sandals right
before right before our our you know new
Darth Vader drone comes in blows his
feet and I and again I'm not even making
light like I'm making it's funny but
it's like I'm I don't like this right
that's why I go on about it yeah but I
will go to that dinner and I'll sit
there and I'll write to check and I'll
go back to my house and I'll swim at
night cuz I like night swimming and if
there's something nice about swimming
it's better than something I'll be uh
I'll have a harem of young men there
that are there because I appreciate
their intellect and what they have to
say all the guys that go out with
they're very smart very smart people
they say what a lot you know what I go
um and and and I will swim in the pool
with those gentlemen and I will I will
think I will thinks I'm a sinker yeah I
not ponder yeah and I'll go I don't walk
this is kind of wacky mm-hmm this is all
not good no now look at and I'll look
out and I'll see this city of the
Satanists and and I'll and I'll and I'll
probably be smoking a cigarette even
though I don't smoke and I will I will
say to myself I would look at the boys
and I'll look at the boys young men and
I'll say to them if I wasn't as
successful do you realize how much worse
it would all be do you realize how much
worse it would all be if I didn't have
this pool and this beautiful home man
you think it's bad now it would be chaos
in the [ __ ] streets
so Tim Dylan comedy calm please get
tickets for the live shows because we
don't want it to get worse we only
wanted to get better I will be at
Mohegan Sun June 20th through the 22nd
skank fest on the 23rd hilarities in
Cleveland July 19th and 20th American
comedy company in San Diego August 1st
through the 3rd stress factory in Jersey
I believe in September coming a comedy
connection of Providence in December
I've got some other things happening we
got new videos dropping very soon Devon
where can people find you you do a lot
of funny videos on YouTube go subscribe
to Devon watch all his videos they are
very funny he's got a podcast called
hate that you love it hate that you love
it uh and where else can people find you
youtube.com
Devon Kosta DVA and cos da that's mostly
where I want you to go but gooder at
Devon cos the same spelling and yeah van
Avery is good on Twitter and Instagram
and we're cutting some new videos
together they're gonna be really funny
we're doing some crazy [ __ ] um still
gonna go to Vegas we're going to Vegas
we're going to Vegas we got a lot of
videos gonna shoot in Vegas to podcast
in Vegas there was this guy I'm gonna
have on the show that gret glider who
seems like a cool dude he's a young guy
and he's actually doing some good [ __ ]
he's got a thing called doner see and
you set up this platform that people can
donate to people in third-world
countries like Malawi this kid lived in
Malawi and he is he's a little like he
set up a platform we could donate to
people get real video update so I'm like
how your money is being used it's kind
of a revolutionary idea I don't know
that much about it so in three weeks
when it comes out that it's a front for
human trafficking don't [ __ ] yell at
me
don't [ __ ] DM me don't tweet me I
just said it looks good from and I want
to have him on the show because like he
seems like a good dude he seems like an
interesting guy
um I really appreciate that I think he's
doing a lot for people it seems like
nowhere near what I'm doing by
broadcasting and telling jokes not even
a little not even a little he's not he's
not fit to you know hold my robe but I
would like to probably have on the show
because I'm kind of curious we're gonna
start bringing some more guests into
we've got some maybe some very
controversial guests oh really
coming up they can't say ah I don't want
to say but Milo you guys but I think I
will say somebody from my past okay
whoo ah I didn't know that well but was
in the in the comedy world for a while
and has had some issues hmm all right I
always say that but was always very very
you know nice guy to me don't agree with
him on everything but I think that would
be very interesting conversation
can I take some guesses there's a uh
yeah there's a joke there's a book
called the is called the joke by this
guy this author Milan Kundera or
something I don't know if I'm
pronouncing that right it's about a joke
that ruined somebody who told a joke and
it ruined their life and I never read
the book but you Michael told me about
it and I should read it but I would say
that this guy
kind of ended up ruining his life or if
not ruining his life it unraveled his
life something that was initially
satirical took on a life of its own and
I think it'll be a very fascinating
conversation you could take some guesses
we'll say who it is I have no problem
saying who it is right nicely no I can't
think of like was on Twitter or eg Santa
joke on stage wasn't a joke it was
something that he did that was initially
satirical that became something that I
think he lost control of and I think
it's spiraled I honestly don't
okay so we'll leave it's okay surprised
yeah it'll be surprised and um we'll see
what happens
but it'll be I got some [ __ ] for it put
it this way okay I'll get some [ __ ] for
Jesus I'll get some [ __ ] for it okay um
because this person has been due
platform done almost everything okay
yeah I will get some [ __ ] for this do
you know who it is but I will tell you
the s my job if I have one and I don't
is to talk to people yeah right yes so
what you have to do in that situation is
people the people that are always gonna
be suspect of your intentions and always
think you have horrible intentions you
gotta say [ __ ] them you can't you can't
go by the people that are gonna give you
[ __ ] and hate you anyway and throw a fit
and do the same horseshit and do the
same stuff and throw the same tantrums
over and over again you really can't
[ __ ] list of those people so I will
have this person on believe in the whole
thing where it's like you're a bad
person forgiving like you're giving
somebody a platform for their evil or
whatever if you're asking the right
questions and putting them on the spot
yeah you're actually doing good because
then they can buy the way everybody's
that are in favor of what they you know
by the way who's giving the CIA a
platform
[Laughter]